pendant que la flamme olympique je suis
son long parcours au japon la charge
canadienne pour un report des jeux faits
faiblir le temps est flexible jusque là
le premier ministre japonais shinzo abe
ouvre une porte il admet qu'un report
pourrait devenir inévitable
en tenant compte en priorité des
athlètes je suis d'ici au canada les
athlètes olympiques et paralympiques
appui en majorité leur fédération
mais émotivement c'est pénible
l'incident la certitude c'est l'enfer ça
fait 12 ans c'est le néant
confiné à son domicile la plongeuse
bellegarde bonne photo s'entraîne comme
elle peut
selon elle le comité olympique canadien
a pris une sage décision et des
compétences at il dit si ça peut se
déplacer on peut les déplacer on peut
les pousser
mais la santé non
la fédération internationale
d'athlétisme mettait déjà de la pression
sur le comité international olympique
pour le report des jeux en 2021
ni faisable ni souhaitable écrit son
président sebastian coe mon patron des
jeux olympiques thomas ce bac avant que
le cio le sel ou dimanche quatre
semaines supplémentaires pour trancher
la question
cet important projet au canada mais à
travers le monde que les gens restent
chez eux
le premier ministre justin trudeau
invite le monde à suivre l'exemple
canadien
même son de cloche à québec l'australie
a imité le canada la suisse la norvège
portugal recommande ou souhaité le
report des jeux
la russie elle précise qu'il ne faut pas
céder à la panique et braun le statu quo
interrogé par léo est cette idée
l'ancien vice-président du cio est
toujours membre influent le montréalais
des cordes a cependant soutenu lundi que
le cio avait déjà pris sa décision de
reporter les jeux jean françois poirier
radio-canada mourir